gummy
stick around make a sound there's more
to people Town hey townies welcome to
another episode of dumb people Town
population
the boss is in the house
basement for those who are watching
gonna bring down some Filipinos Pizza
some flautas
oh you know what I love that I gotta get
back in my house a deli Mex chicken
Taquito there you go best chicken
Taquitos in the world Los cuatro Milpas
down in San Diego you have to go really
in the world yes
this is how authentic the Mexican it's
Mexican food so authentic that with each
Taquito they give you Taquito they give
you a crying baby yeah you just get one
and you're like do I have to take care
of this yeah yeah that's your
responsibility for the rest of your life
so Al magical you're here the world is
still dumb it is since the last time
you've been on the show I would argue in
a while it's got even dumber yeah right
a lot of dumb people while we're
trending we're trending and the only way
to fight it Daniel Van Kirk our arrow is
down the only way to fight it is through
comedy and we get great stories sent in
by our awesome fans and uh so shall we
let's dive into one jump and then we'll
talk about what else into because yeah
she's doing great stuff as I'm gonna do
it from my phone because that's the way
we do it here and this is how we gonna
do it I've been scrolling through emails
right now I'm just going through email
just getting through some junk mails all
right ready for this yes sir here's the
it was sent in by Lacey Davidson at
Lacey jd18 Lacy JD 18. I don't think
that Lacey is sent in before so it's not
familiar this is a brand new person
thank you girl all you got to do is uh
at dump or hashtag dump people town at
Squad brothers and Danny Van Kirk on
Twitter I believe still Twitter is
happening is Twitter's still around I
keep wondering Elle are you on Twitter
I've been the worst with social media
since it came out so you mean the best
so this is
not doing it off my phone is how you
know someone unsuccessful they're like
I'm not on social media and you're like
oh yeah
I think I'm I'm gonna quit it but I
found out I can still search our stories
is and and I no one can take it
personally if you do everybody but uh
down I've unfollowed everybody on
Instagram so that feels good it does
feel that God feel good and then you
blocked your whole family and that's
fine that was a weird thing your son is
like why is my dad doing he's not
returning any of my taxes it's coming up
green why you didn't need to do a full
cleanse anyway so let me get into this
headline the headline's great and in the
headline we will try and determine who
is correct in this story and who who is
I think who's the [__] right okay
okay Utah woman all right I already hate
her no heavy drinker no she's been
through a lot let's just started she's
battling with another woman to be
someone's wife Utah woman forced to give
ex-husband
forced to give ex-husband I don't like
that and I don't ever forcing of ex-hub
husband Boudoir album in divorce
listen divorce is hard okay you just
want it to be a clean break right you
just if you divorce someone clean break
what's your feeling on it instantly
Boudoir yeah like sexy photo shoot no no
no I got that but to have a Boudoir
like these are wealthy people right all
right so should we go to the bedroom or
the beautiful
wealthy people call it Boudoir Photos
everyone else calls it dick pics
I have no idea why have you guys ever
taken the tick tock challenge are you on
you're on Tick Tock
hell no okay what is it
it's a thing that uh I've seen they do
around offices or whatever where men
have to scroll how many tick tocks they
get to before it's something like sexy
or like like [__] woman or whatever or
[__] man and um
as I keep seeing these tick tocks for
Boudoir shoots everything else on my
thing is like sports uh gambling uh
animals
yes and I'm 100 and I have a whole bit
about how a tech talk tells you exactly
who you are as a person so I think that
Tick Tock wants me to do a Boudoir shoot
they're not even there's nothing sexy
about it I hear the name the word
Boudoir yes and I just think of a Dusty
pillow someone gotta dust out that pill
just shake it out with an older French
woman smoking into the pillow
what do you want to do with this okay so
we know what it is so divorce would you
want it on your knees
okay God why are you why are you not
excited about it
that was German too anyway shoulders are
back okay
smoosh them together okay uh so who's
wrong do right now let's just take it go
here there's a 100 temperature check
he's wrong for forcing her to give him
the Boudoir album into any sort of like
nudity being sent to you is under the
consent well it is constantly being real
she didn't want to give it up the
Boudoir album they printed out the
photos
he shouldn't want it either it should
just you know what I would do a cool
couple would do toss them in a fire
together yes together but I don't blame
her for saying someday later on in my
life I might want to look back and be
like Jim Rome said it I'll say he said
if you take a picture it's gonna find
its way out into the world either in the
world or it's gonna it's gonna come back
but if that picture has only made it to
one other person I agree and they were
married when they did it it should only
be they did it the right way you want it
and how does he get it is my question
through the court no I know but we'll
get into this whole story but here's
what I know it's one clear India just
get visitation rights him him I get it
every second week I get to be with it at
a playground while someone else watches
me him or 45 minutes every other Tuesday
him ordering the book is a clear sign
that he's going to move on from this all
right exactly you never want to be like
have lingering creepiness no like okay
Utah woman has been forced to hand over
an edited Boudoir album of racy nude
photos of her uh to to her ex-husband as
part of their divorce so he can keep the
loving messages accompanying them for
memory sake so that's why he argued oh
because there's notes in there yeah
there's notes in there so if I'm her and
I don't want him to have it
bye yeah you can't find it it's 100
right it's burnt that's true it's
destroyed yeah
to give right but I guess you could go
to Shutterfly and reorder it if you
cared about it if he cared about it
or like like eight years from now it
comes up in his memories yeah yeah 12
years ago
your phone that's sad iPhone does [__]
with you Lindsay Marsh who sounds like
she's like the 5 p.m news woman yeah
that's great told KSL news that a judge
forced her to distribute basically porn
after ruling that her husband of how
many years
how long were they married he broke up
with him no no Boudoir yeah
that's at least seven I'm saying uh
husband of 37 years old whoa damn what
do you think I'm gonna go 11 years Jay
what are you 19 years get your answers
in time to shout at your ham radios or
if you're watching this on the YouTube
channel the ATC YouTube channel it's a
good thing it's a long you never know
yeah after ruling that her husband of 25
years Jason nice job had the right to
keep the intimate messages she scrawled
across the album my message is fine
while the judge eventually allowed her
to have the racy photos edited so now
she's gotta go and edit these things
she's gonna blur stuff out and whatnot
he still knows what was there he
remembers the things so they're obscured
in order to feel less violated to me why
is a judge allowing this to happen do
you know what I'm saying he wants the
messages just say you can have the
message you can have the messages but no
photos Dan also why do you want the
messages this is my thing too first of
all I'm 100 on hers I don't think she
should have to give anything back no and
I agree without like hey you know what I
accidentally burnt
um we had an oven fire right what was
the book was in the book well you just
cleaned out sorry go ahead don't go no
you I was saying we just did a big sort
of I hired a home organizer and we got a
great idea everything
my kids hated her it was hilarious
because I got the whole family around
the holidays who's this woman is why is
she bossing us around like she doesn't
know where stuff goes oh you're
literally living in a sitcom this is a
perfect sitcom episode one episode and
you're like I don't know I'm gonna get
to the bottom
you're working on that box you're
working on that box anyway so we came
across the box of Father's Day cards yes
and Mother's Day quotes
we had them in a box I kept everything
sure but I was like hey honey remember
this one I started reading him she's
like yeah yeah just put it in the Box
no no no we kept everything but it was
like it ended up being all this
memorabilia there yeah yeah sure like we
are all in stand-up comedy we always run
across that creepy club owner creepy
Club manager that wants to show you a
picture of his wife's boobs yeah I don't
want to see your wife I don't want to
see your boobs why is this good for
anyone I don't know what I don't want to
know what you like and what I don't see
your name out of this you want me to
think about this while I'm asking I
barely want to eat here even a gun eyes
that go like I've rarely run across this
but guys want to talk about like sex but
then you know that they're married and
I'm like I don't want to think about
yeah I barely want the lightly battered
chicken
breasts there anyway so it's violating
an incredibly that's what he wants to do
with it right yeah that's what he wants
so she she told the Salt Lake Tribune
she's going to the Salt Lake Tribune on
this okay I agree with her I'm surprised
they're even running the story even hand
even having to hand over the messages is
violating she insisted and I agree these
are things that were sensual and loving
that I wrote to my husband that I loved
and you know she pushed the Ed on that
one uh speaking of VD that's probably
the reason why my husband now she said
uh Lindsay Marsh is being forced by the
judge to give the Boudoir photo okay the
only way I can hopefully protect someone
else from going through the same
situation is tell my story and expose
that these types of types of things that
he thinks are okay so she's now trying
to ruin any any further relationship he
has with anybody else oh by the way if
you're dating this guy and you're
thinking about getting involved with
this guy he's going to take pictures of
you and he will use them against you
don't go into the Boudoir they're going
in the album Chris Marsh fought to keep
uh he was the winner here Mark said the
Boudoir album was the only thing that
her ex fought to keep during the whole
thing that's the only thing this guy's a
creep creep great Davis County Judge now
do you think the judge was a man or a
woman woman it shouldn't matter but
probably I'm definitely saying man what
do you think I'm gonna sadly agree
Michael Edwards okay he's got two for
two male names Michael and Edward
ordered the album uh would have to be
handed over so that the words are
maintained from memory but I'm gonna
need to see it in my chamber
I will have to leave through it all rise
however the photos could be given to the
original photographer to do whatever it
takes to modify them so that any pics of
Martian lingerie and that sort of thing
even without clothing is obscure to
taken out the judge wrote in a ruling
share with both list the photographer a
close friend initially refused to edit
the picture because her so they got
closer to the photographer now who has
Artistic integrity over the photos they
took is that why they're saying they
don't want to know because her clients
trust would you ask Ansel Adams to edit
his photos right exactly Diane Arbus
yeah this is like the 25 years is
perfect because pre-sell phone you've
been married almost 25 years right I've
been I'm closing it on 24 years I'm 20.
you're in your 21st June yeah 22 this
June okay yeah there you go so there you
go so another what are you 14 I'm 19 I'm
19. do I prefer to edit someone she
believes her ex-husband knew she told
the outlet she was so panicked she
called the judge's clerk's office to
check that it was not an error that's
that's how much of a weird ruling this
was she called the clerk so I was being
like you guys screwed up right you guys
[__] this thing up and no and this is
the type of situation that used to
happen all the time like these guys
might be Loosely Affiliated it's Utah
I'm saying that's oh my God that's true
this is like an LDS like it's like an
Elders thing let's pass it around to the
elders listen to her quote and this is
so great because this is her quote to
the Tribune sure okay and I love the way
she puts this in a way that you know
she's speaking as slowly as possible I
just want to clarify the judge has
ordered me to ordered me to give nude
photos of my body to a third party that
I don't know without my consent that's
what she's saying and I love that she's
like I'm not wild there's like there
should be a gag order and I'm talking
about the photos too that is part of the
order hearing the judge's order the
original photographer agreed to alter
the photos so what I would do with the
photos is I would put like I'd black the
whole thing out either black the whole
thing out or put like the worst image
like the mother from Throw Mama From the
train throw that photo on there you know
like Matt Rocky Dennis Master
the thing that for a long time was the
thing that everyone had Snuggie or that
yeah yeah you just put her put her every
photo she should be able to photoshop
them as much as you want but leave the
message intact right so however photo is
however Marsh understands from
discussions between their attorneys that
her husband is not happy with the edited
photos good good
you son of a [__] I'm happy you're not
happy with the book sheet I love that
that's gotten back to her to me that's
the best shot ever any woman that he
dates going forward is going to Google
his name before that first day there you
go after the whole case and this is
going to come up but just why does it
have to be her like you know being a guy
that's married for as long as we've been
married you can find other stuff on the
internet this is a [__] you right that's
right this is like so she clearly broke
up with him she ended the marriage and
he's like this is my only way to get
back I've complied with the Court's
order even though I believe strongly uh
that the order is violating on so many
levels she felt humiliated that she even
took those photos uh again from years
ago and had to edit the photos
away you are denying them personal or
intimate access to you going forward
that's it like I know you guys are all
uh you're all you know happily married
and everything but like you know we live
in a world of like nudes and everybody
sends each other nudes when you end a
relationship if somebody goes hey delete
all my nudes
I've never sent a nude is that crazy I
mean young people will be like what are
you doing so Marsh has been ordered more
about coming in and going out Marsh has
been ordered to keep the original album
for 90 days in case her ex demands new
edits so he can demand his final cut
album afterwards the only book I'm ever
in favor of burning I love you and I
love you Elle after which she plans a
burning party right to finally torch the
painful memories done it's gonna be
amazing and I think everybody should be
naked at the burning parties yeah wrong
is that bad is this the new Burning Man
Chris Marsh claimed the images were not
as intimate as ex-wife had said who
cares many had been posted online or had
hung in their home who cares I cherish
the loving memories we've had for all
those years you should know you don't
you you were in it don't no as part of a
normal and appropriate exchange between
husband and wife maybe they were but now
you are no longer you are not changed
and sought to preserve that and having
the inscriptions he said he noted that
his ex-wife's take on the order was not
my uh perspective nor the perspective of
an impactful judge so what's up what's
the final deal with this that just that
she's gotta make these edits and do that
so I'm gonna show you I mean I I don't
know
maybe went to college with this guy he's
not his friend but he doesn't have some
of the photos so here's is that just her
or is that a Boudoir that's just her
this is her doing the splits in a
waterfall well that's great she's got a
bathing suit on but I mean that these
are not the photos though I'm gonna show
you the guy this is the guy the this is
what he looks like does this guy seem
like anything he's a finance bro we'll
post these up he's a finance bro he's
the worst guy he's like he's the guy
who's wearing like he's definitely gonna
get killed on season three of White
Lotus yeah
[Laughter]
killed in the first episode like it's
not even the Cliffhanger in this photo
he's wearing a vest which means you're
kind of cold but in this area not all
the way shortly short sleeve shirt I'm
like you can't wear shorts in front of
the boat so it looks like a thing also
the you they people go into Patagonia
and say can I have the finance bro vest
shut up it really is a date they I know
somebody who works at a Patagonia says
they get requested that all the time you
know the other thing that started
because of succession just blank black
hats black hats these three four hundred
dollar blank hats that has become like a
huge in New York and like rich people so
this is so so by the way I think this is
my solution for it in your prenup or
whatever you or if you ever take these
photos you sign an agreement that says
if anything happens between us there's
gonna have to be destroyed and they can
never be there again right these kinds
tracks have to be drawn up so if you're
a lead if you're a legal person out
there or a lawyer or I guess that's what
they're called you draw these things up
this could be almost specialize it yes
specialize in in the destruction of dick
pics and laying out the groundworks
ahead of time it's an emerging food it's
an expanding feeling it's ever growing
guys that is the first story down in the
books when we come back we'll find out
what Al Madrigal is up to he's got some
great stuff going on and Dan and us and
the live dumb people time we're doing uh
it's coming together in the best
possible way up at San Francisco sketch
Fest February 5th we'll talk about it
after the break this is dumb people town
with Al madrigo we'll be right back
hey guys welcome back to the show
welcome back we got Al Madrigal here uh
before we mention what he's doing we
need to make a big deal out of this
because I want to sell it out I I would
be the desire this is the first time
we've been on the road with this show
maybe since the pandemic right no no
what's wrong what's wrong with you hold
on first time we've been back to San
Francisco sorry you were in the right
you were actually been at a festival in
San Francisco first time we've ever done
this podcast no it's the first time
we're unveiling it at sketch fast it's
at Cobbs Comedy Club which is one of the
best clubs in the country but it's big
so we want to fill it with you guys 100
seats let's fill it I really do one of
our 381 San Francisco however 15 20
people
having a nightclub called wolfgangs and
ask when you're there to go in the
basement because the basement is the
exact same size as the venue
that is my hometown that is my home
comedy club that's a comedy club that
first started working me along with the
punchline yeah and uh San Francisco
people come out in force to see this
show this show will be amazing so we've
got uh Robbie Hoffman who is so great
she hasn't been on the show I love her
she's such a funny comedian she's like
if Larry David were used to be a used to
be a Hasidic woman is now a lesbian
right now and hilarious she's so good
Eva Kim our friend Eva Kim is going to
be DJing which will be fantastic and
then we're working on uh potentially one
more guess we'll let you know when it
happens and I bet we'll be going over
the things we gotten stuck inside us
last year all right wonderful it's it's
a traditional tradition yeah so that's
on February 5th uh that weekend before
Jay and I are going to be in San Diego
at the American Comedy Company uh
Thursday through Saturday night and then
we'll be up in San Francisco and I will
be there taquitos yeah yeah the night
before on the fourth doing stand-up and
uh I'm doing the risk show story I love
Kevin Allison's so great uh so
danielvankirk.com superscars.com Al
people can see you on Lopez V Lopez
right that is Friday nights at eight
o'clock even if you do not watch it
please record it yeah DVR it just leave
it on lead a play I don't care if you
watch it right uh you can watch it
really well I just heard a story about
great I just heard a story about George
Lopez and Aaron am I allowed to say this
story or no
okay I just want to talk about just
because Jay and I got a chance to work
with Lopez on his TBS show years ago we
did a little he came in as the as the
race as the racist Warner Brothers but
we weren't racist we were like from
another time period they shot Us in
black and white and everything we were
saying was racist also it was so funny
that I broke three times and ruined the
sketch and I'm like oh this is why I'm
not ever asked to do sketches on The
Late Night show so but it was really
funny I also did sketches on Lopez
tonight I was a Chilean Miner remember
when the Chilean yeah
and then I was also a Latino Abraham
Lincoln I don't remember this guy by the
way I love it I love both
so uh so we so Lopez was at like uh
auction and he and he was at Dodger
Stadium with Albert Pujols Aaron our
wonderful uh producer and engineer uh is
a huge St Louis Cardinals fan and there
was going to be a pool halls jersey
signed up for sale at this auction and
Lopez bought it for Aaron bought it
before it could go up for auction which
he probably you know it probably would
have sold for more so I don't know
he did not live but he bought it see him
donating a significant amount of money
I'm sure he did yeah and so he bought
this thing so it sold for a good amount
of money and then he gave it to Aaron
that's awesome isn't that great but so I
love this beautiful generous gift and
knowing that it's just pretty Aaron you
love it
it's so cool and it just makes me love
the guy on that reason alone go watch
the show Lopez very generous dude and
he's doing it with his daughter Mayan
Lopez it's his real life daughter and
it's just it really is a group everyone
says this but it's the most delightful
people and George is like a really funny
generous dude I play a big Stoner yes
and um love it it's great was there a
little bit of method acting going on
you'd be the judge you'd be the judge
watch it don't drug test him on the set
and uh so watch that Friday nights uh
Lopez versus Lopez that's awesome all
right let's jump into another story
number two uh I'm gonna read the
headline and again this is I don't know
if this woman is the dummy or if the
people are the dummies
horror after she ended up sitting on
super glued swing in Vile prank oh
that's horrible that okay
man who just Flex sealed his entire home
because of the storm of course these
super glues are insane they are really
nuts but
I feel like
they are also quick drying yes and This
Woman's a real [__] dummy right
because you would have seen like a wet
swing thank you what is that hey
let me just sit in it could be enough to
stick her to bottom to the seat into the
swing it had to be a significant amount
the horrible pranks horrible horrible
Horror by the way the best ad ever for
Flex Seal is this woman walking around
with dragging chains of a circle is
amazing are you do you do pranks I I I
used to do April fools but wait but my
father you're in your special your
father in my special it's a true story
when a ballet studio oh yeah and I did
shrimp my daughter's ballet shrimp the
hell out of it shrimping ain't easy it's
an unbelievable special he shrimped it I
hid I hid shrimp but that's more a
vendetta that is a vendetta
the pranks were you know I'd tease my
dad yeah yeah but like whoever is right
this is just mean like Prank Wars
stressed me out yes children sitting on
this so here we go and and what about
bare skin oh
woman found herself in a sticky
situation oh my God is this the New York
Post no but God damn you kind of right
when she sat on a child's swing
smothered smothered was this a menu at a
Southern Restaurant barbecue sauce we
smothered these biscuits yeah by the way
smothered also to me like sounds like
you did something inhumane to whatever
piece of chicken it's very rare that we
have something that denotes killing
someone and being like delicious or
being like a Jewish mother okay me
smothered this chicken firefighters had
to use petrol Fire by the way that it so
I was gonna say that breaks down right
yeah oil oil breaks natural gas uh to
deactivate the super glue and free the
woman from the playground it is thought
that vandos maliciously smeared the
strong adhesive onto the swing in a
wicked prank Wicked prank the swing
could have been used by an unsuspect
toddler this is what you were saying or
or before the woman fell victim to the
Trap so also I'm also wondering why is
have you been we all went to parks with
our kids
I remember the last time I got on us
yeah little kids going to be on your lap
and they don't have the the little sort
of bucket swings or the wherewithals I'm
gonna ask you guys a question growing up
did you ever do the swing and then let
yourself do a backflip
it became a big thing in Rochelle Dan
you did not do a backflip off three days
before the end of school no Brandon
Watson oh boy goes He spins he does the
backflip over his arms get caught no in
the chains no he breaks both of his arms
God damn it three days before summer so
just this so he's insisting all summer
guys it's just this I was too scared to
ever I never did I would do the jump you
know big jump off yeah let me change
scared to Smart big jumpers and then
that's the end you were smart my move
with the kids when they were little and
this kills for all young parents out
there I would get my toddler and they
were going in the swing and I would look
at it a leaf or anything a little twig
and I go hey I'm gonna pick this up
under no circumstances will you kick me
in the booty
open it up wide and just let them have
that and that do like the biggest
problem
just destroyed that's sad best out of
here
it's a great digit we hear the problem
you know what the pranksters did also
when they put the petrol on there they
came and they lit it on fire that's so
excessive after the fire department they
came in like
I love that someone you know obviously
people comment uh one person said what's
wrong with these people uh one said
great but by the way great comments
exactly they had so much comment on this
right here
man what's the best of that then this
person's comment to me might be the
dumbest thing ever said about this not
the last one not this one what is what
is worrying is who walks around with
glue this is what you're worried about
it's either done on purpose or they're
on glue they're on glue they're on glue
they're on glue so so do you obviously
you're old enough to remember this the
old Reese's peanut butter commercials
where like the woman is sitting in the
at the movie theater at the movie
theater with an open jar the guy sitting
with an open jar of peanut butter and
the guy from the balcony like yeah he's
scared by the movie and then like a
piece of chocolate drops in
I'm like who is [__] what psycho is
showing up to a movie theater with just
an open jar of peanut butter and pawing
it out like a bear enjoy this movie I
can't talk right now I gotta stick my
open hand into a jarpine that should not
be allowed in any way shape or form like
I hope coven stopped that no but there
was another commercial where two people
were walking I showed this to my
daughters I was like you guys this is
the dumbest thing ever you know how you
like raises peanut butter cups watch how
stupid this is two people walking around
a corner a man and a woman she's holding
an open jar of peanut butter and he
bumps into her hey your peanut butter is
in my chocolate your chocolate my peanut
butter hey an [__] why are you
walking around with open peanut butter
it's so unsanitary I just got my food
you know at any sporting event yes I got
my food and then you have to walk
especially if it's at halftime yeah to
leave like this the weave with the
sneeze in there breathing in the middle
you eat a dome Garden yeah
uh this is crazy so Yorkshire Fire and
Rescue Services so this is in England
sent to the park to rescue the woman a
crew from Bedale was called into the
FEMA whose hand had become stuck on the
chain of the Swing so it wasn't in the
seat of the Swing it's in the it's on so
you put your hands on the chain and then
now you're stuck you're stuck to the
thing and you can't how did she call I
don't even know is there a chance she
was targeted
this woman should get it and I'm looking
at this woman this adult woman and like
she's the type of person that would get
on a swing let's lather him up well it
just the fact that you don't see this
gooey ass swing just sitting there I
mean if it's on the chains half a dried
bird turd I'm looking for it but this is
on the chains on the side I'm gonna put
this in the same category of like adult
coloring books and adult kickball league
adults at Disneyland you don't need to
do that you don't need to get in the
swing like I'm not playing the Victor
but by the way I would say in every
single scenario and Al's character on
Lopez versus Lopez would agree with me
if you're [__] up yeah all those
things are wonderful then it's all then
it's all then then you're into the games
then you're into then I've I've
definitely done some drunk swinging
before sure
if you're high swinging and this happens
to you then you're like this only
happens when you're high this only
happens when I'm hungry you'd also be in
denial like I'm not really stuck this
isn't happening I can hold for the
helicopter please yeah right holding uh
over the summer uh Crews were called to
a swath of incidents this is the only
time people got stuck in swings we're
teenagers to squeeze themselves into the
tiny rubber child seats and it was
sparked by a tick tock challenge which
encouraged youngsters to get inside
while being filmed so the bucket seats
where the legs go through they're trying
to get in there so no you that's dummies
one toddler game one County saw how many
teens have to be cut free in a space
with the jaws of life cut free in the
space of two months in the space of two
months in the two months in one area I
guess maybe one set of apartments with
the same number I predicted on that
marriage 37 37 what do you say yeah I'm
gonna say 26. oh I'm gonna drop that
down by 20. I'm gonna go six six six get
your answers in shout and this is from
from The Tick Tock challenge okay
similar people getting stuck in swings
one County saw 18 teams wow very good
Mary Side Fire and Rescue Services said
14 of those incidents happened in May
alone there's no way all those teens
didn't know each other which required
them to dismantle the whole swing so
like at least one of them saw their
friends get stuck and we're like who's
the dummy that keeps putting the swing
back right all right yeah you lose it
you want to cut it it's just like we're
done with it we don't get we we've
proven we don't have time to be on
swings and again since we are so old
remember what they were back in the day
yeah they were metal they were metal
they were metal swings yeah
and the other thing is we can't have
nice swings to me this this is the
definition of criminal mischief though
isn't it it's totally putting super glue
on a swing that's criminal but if I
could find the person who did this to me
also like how much you guys would know
this with your kids playgrounds are
drastically different from when we were
little oh yes because when I feel like
it was just metal bars assembled in some
way that you could climb around yeah and
then like a 40-foot steel slide that was
like if you you would slide and you just
like a kid stick who learned to walk
within the last year and a half climb up
to the top of this thing and then go
down and then a merry-go-round that
would just fling kids off into wood
chips San Francisco city zoo was one of
the most treacherous places they had
just a uh and and that playground you're
talking about just all metal all metal
sharp edges that metal death trap and I
had knives nearby that have you guys
heard about Monkey Island no no idea
here that's the name of this episode
pyramid with no emote around a cement
pyramid threw some monkeys on where is
this this was the old San Francisco Zoo
there was a tree oh that's how they love
to live Monkey Island well by the way I
mean by the way you told me Monkey
Island was a new flavor of Ben and
Jerry's I'd be like yeah for a great
bars
wait what happened they've all just died
it was just like you know like like
magic
the monkey's smoking and stuff just like
little owls on a 65 foot slide that's
where they'd throw the the Poo at you of
course but why wouldn't you at this
point but my dad used to and I were
completely but my dad that's when they
let you bring food and feed the animals
too so my dad would bring Al Madrigal
would take in a huge bag of Granny Smith
apples and just throw it just Chuck them
right into the bear's mouth feeding the
Bears so the Bears
growing fastballs into a bear's mouth
because this guy right here is throwing
a fastball a high fastball into the
Granny's the guy behind your dad's got
two buckets of KFC when you're done man
I'm just I brought this Chuck this
chicken out and see what happens what
about the bones what about them
one monitoring at all dude Monkey Island
tells me that no one was bothering
anything
we let the kids go that was the same Zoo
where the kids snuck in and uh stole the
koalas too at Christmas to give to their
girlfriends that's
nobody is that a dumb people Town
nobody's written a book about the
free-for-all that was the San Francisco
Zoo yeah oh my God it is ridiculous I
love it all right well there you go
there's Story number two story number
two dad of the books Daniel can give us
a little taste of them oh you know what
it is what is it uh
it's bad stuff on an airplane I love it
but not in the way we're used to hearing
we'd fly we all fly so much and you
again passengers are the way we're used
to hearing baby highly jacking it no
it's not sexual and it's not like uh
violent all right we'll hear all of that
on the other side of this break I can't
wait the hell magic was with us it's
dumb people Town don't go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show uh Al
Madrigal is with us we were just talking
the break about our patreon which is so
fun we've sort of changed the uh change
the tenor of it right and what you're
getting and which very it's much more
interactive with you guys first of all
the level is five dollars a month if
you're at a different level and you want
to stay there because you're just a true
ba who wants to prove your love go for
it but otherwise it's five bucks so you
jump on and you get all this extra stuff
what we're doing now and this is what
you guys can do is you write in and tell
us a dumb story from your life and we
will break it down so the three of us
tell us your Monkey Island tell us your
Monkey Island right you will break it
down Daniel will take us home feel free
to include a photo of the incident or
your time or how old you were when that
when it had a monkey anything you want
you we will spin if you want to hear us
break down your life here we go it's so
much fun it's inside bucks plus you get
ad free apps okay
in this was sent in by we talk about
practice at not a game not underscore AI
great great deal okay about practice in
flight theft on Buenos Aires to Miami
flight so this is like a Liam Neeson
movie okay but
hold on yes 12 hour flight
any flight to Miami you should expect to
have your [__] stolen there's gonna be
something going down
I did a new work to Miami that was a
rough flight yeah it really was really
yes how many pre-boards a lot just it
was insane I fight alert yeah because
you know we get in a situation where
like you tell your kids everybody look
alive everybody get heads up we don't
know like who's going to terrorists in
Miami damn right there with Steph right
and who's the least of what you can't
look alive for 12. who was uh what was
the line like for feel free to fly now
you're free to fly free to move about
the country fly the friendly Skies
remember that yeah if you're flying to
Miami the the tagline is if you see
something say something that feels like
that's a bad tagline I don't know if you
guys do this I assume you do this is a
pro tip for anybody who travels whether
it's as much as us or once a year
Everyone likes to put their carry-on bag
above their see sure stupid put your
carry-on bag across the aisle from you
above so you can see it the whole time
anybody because somebody just says you
have no idea if it starts fishing around
up there I always think
and protein no no no no no
when somebody even moves yeah no even
somebody you better be looking for a
jacket or someone moves it why'd you
move my jacket I go hey you need a
little help up there what's going on
yeah everything good Dan Dan with the
deep blue
you get up there you good you good eat
anything you need a hand do you want me
to move something for you that's it
because my things are in close right up
somebody in your hand I have a jacket I
have a backpack I have a Boudoir book
okay it's all up there any of that [__]
is touched we're in the bulkhead right
and you are forced to put your carry on
um you know you're you're just like
giving your personal bank your personal
bank you've got to throw it across from
you you're totally that's a great great
call all right so what happen theft
police were called to meet American
Airlines flight AA 900 from Buenos Aires
that's easy to Miami M.I.A on the
morning of July 5th 2022 according to
court documents a passenger stole how
much money
in flight from a person
stole in Flight I'm Gonna Save five
thousand dollars okay what do you think
if it's 5 000 argentinians by the end of
the flight that it was worth nothing
um
yeah five thousand is a good guess I'm
gonna say 1500 bucks I'm gonna say eight
hundred dollars
they stole it and this isn't all they
stole but in US dollars from this person
they stole
ten thousand twenty two dollars oh my
gosh that's more than you could enter
the United States with you have to
declare but we're going to Miami okay
was this in the shape or form of a fight
every dollar was already rolled into a
straw okay okay I love how I'm all about
the rules but you can't travel with them
uh did we mention it's going to Miami he
stole uh ten thousand dollars plus two
credit cards from passengers seven
thousand oh a variety of passengers ten
thousand I think was from one person
alone and then the credit cards were
from other people by the way and this
isn't even seven thousand dollars of
that money is used should have been to
pay the custom agents to look the other
way
seven goes to them wait wait wait so
cred how does he get people's credit
cards because some people will take
their purse and leave it there or their
wallet out of their back pocket and put
it into the when you think in front and
then they just go to the bathroom I saw
a viral video Once of somebody who went
to the bathroom came back and it was
like two three thousand dollars and he
was saying he goes someone on this
flight took three thousand dollars from
me I'm not a violent person but none of
us are getting off this [__]
flight until everyone because you know
this is why I said it's like a Liam
Neeson movie you know someone else
we're gonna take everybody row by row
I'm gonna be asking up your wallet open
up your wall we'll be touching your wife
what no if you have ten thousand dollars
on you I don't care if it's a flight
dude or the San Francisco Zoo
traveler Aaron you're traveling with
Aaron Rodgers
discount double check the issue came to
light after flight attendants observed
suspicious Behavior including a
passenger repeatedly walking up and down
the aisle and sitting for an extended
period of time
that's it that's it heads up to these
flights
that's not you this is by the way this
isn't like the end of a Cubs game
do you remember the Chicago Comedy
Festival when they used to do that and
it was like a Montreal thing it's the
same yeah yeah
so we and we it was one of those things
where they had a party for us in the
bowling alley and I knew everybody right
sure and that's everyone was getting
Sauced up my flight was at six a.m okay
this is a smart move like you're like at
some point you're like I'm staying up
all night I did it I was like but people
were getting sauce yeah and it was just
going to stop I some comic wanted to I
just uh spacing on it who it is and he
wanted to fight they wanted to fight me
because I called his girlfriend a bad
bowler
isn't she such a good bowler when I go
look where I go oh really yeah I've seen
a lot of bowling and uh I don't think
she's doing it not that great you're
good and that's how drunk people were
yeah
yeah you [__] say that to me
saying your girlfriend's not a good
bowler to me has to be said in a like a
mafia style yay your girlfriend's not a
good boy
she's a horrible bowler what's the
opposite of a good witch
you come into our lane you come into our
lane and you say that to me you know
what your girlfriend is a good bowler
with a circle around her and a line
through it
eight foot foul it is interesting when
you do the all night I have to fly out
the next morning because you you just
get to watch the night deteriorate
because you're not you have nowhere to
go but I was part of the deterioration
so I get I can't believe I made it to my
flight yeah I had been traveling so much
at that point so I'm In First Class yeah
and everybody to get their meal and I'm
like I gotta go to a bathroom and so I
got up and I was in the bathroom for an
hour and for an extended period of time
for the time somebody pounds on the door
oh [__] boom boom boom like that and I
remember opening up and there's this
little Latino uh Steward and I go who
did that and he goes it was him
and there's this guy standing in the
Middle with his arms crossed which means
if you had looked right you would have
figured it out
wasted still yeah and I go hey
you battle on the door and I could let
me explain to you how Airline bathrooms
this is a middle of a flight In First
Class yeah In First Class bro let me
explain you now wow no so dumb
um
[Laughter]
he did look like Sam the eagle from the
Muppets yeah okay Jeffrey Tambor and
um I I go hey man let me explain to you
how airplane bathrooms work red light on
yeah you don't come in you don't come up
you don't even get out of your seat what
are you doing pounding like there's one
in the back you walk to the back yeah
and then he goes you were in there for
very long ago I was in there for as long
as I was in there you got it I was drunk
in a bowling alley two hours ago just
waste trash yeah and I swear to you a
image of my wife appeared over my
I just went
it's in mid-sentencies
she's your guardian angel uh eye mask
and just headphones blanket because
they're done well you were in the
bathroom long enough to have [__] stolen
from you right had you left something on
your seat a laptop certainly and that's
the thing is that I have heard stories
like this of people trying to take
laptops oh yeah and there's think about
all the electronics are left and also
when you're going through TSA and I take
my wallet out I take my keys out I take
everything out and I sort of throw it in
a zipped pocket and then here's all my
goods you know my valuables in the
zipped pocket so this guy is kudos to
these guys for picking it up another
crew member observed the passenger with
a wallet that looked like it belonged to
a female it's a little bit of gender
assignment the flight crew advise
passengers in the area to search their
belongings to see if anything was
missing one passenger confirmed that ten
thousand and twenty two dollars and
thirteen thousand eight hundred
Argentinian Pesos which is about
25.00 109 bucks thank you uh anyone
thinks that anyone we're making fun of
Argentina and their current collapse you
could go to Argentina I think in the
early 2000s and buy a hotel for thirty
thousand dollars you could but you could
like use I was there so I went to
Argentina in 2005. oh I was in Buenos
Aires and we got we went to the nicest
restaurant in town and got a steak
dinner the steak is unbelievable two
nights in a row it was 40 bucks perfect
40 American dollars I mean it was
probably like 12. so this woman is
missing over ten thousand ten thousand
twenty two bucks crazy and 109 American
dollars worth of uh Argentinian Pesos
another passenger inspected her
belongings after hearing about the
situation and noticed that she was
missing 720 we're gonna we're almost up
to 11 000. this dude is like
520 dollars in pesos which is 444 US
Dollars and two credit cards after being
searched it was determined that the
thief had two credit cards in his
possession matching the name of another
traveler furthermore a passenger was
able to identify some of the bills in
The thief's Possession based on unique
stamps some of the bills had on them
that's great who stamps you're marking
your own bills I love it Mark your own
bills trying to catch someone ready one
question by police the passenger
admitted that he had stolen from other
passengers big kudos to the American
Airlines crew for being so so if you
admitted this after he takes your stuff
do we get to beat on him while we're in
the in the air what do you what happens
then in the in the air oh got me it's
probably a federal offense right now
you're stuck in the air though
by the way you're in a federal he
admitted it after they stepped off his
neck it's like Randy Moss yeah
um going down on a flight when you're on
a flight are you guys up and involved
it just depends who's to me I'm like
just please I've thrown out a like hey
let's take it easy over here I've had
people like sexually going at it on a
flight oh yeah and I'm like you're doing
it stop looking at me I'm enjoying this
yeah
you're the one why am I the evil person
do you know I used to know the Safeway
near the San Francisco punch line that's
down low in the Embarcadero yeah I
watched the most epic movie fight in
there a guy the security guard just had
had enough this guy was shoplifting and
San Francisco homeless this is a whole
nother subject and of course this guy
was had a backpack full of [__] and the
security guard was like not today the
thief grabbed the security guard and
threw him through the window in a pile
of strawberry like a strawberry display
strawberry seasoning oh God everywhere
the most epic fight in a strawberry
juice we don't know no it's just
strawberry fight and finally Isaac
enough
very loud
stop this now yeah and turn both gosh
that's right I was like oh that's a game
your wife to them
Christian Madrigal jumped in here stop
it now it's strawberries just make great
tres leche cake no she does know how to
stop a fight she can be your personal
thing Al Madrigal thank you for joining
us on dumb people done this is a great
job
fast and furious I love this if you love
this show again listen to it on wherever
you listen to podcasts you can check
that out or you can watch and watch
YouTube give it a nice comment give it a
nice comment that up too we love you
guys and uh oh [__] we gotta get back to
work
stick around make a sound there's more
to people town
[Music]